Now, many have wondered
why I've yet to weigh in
on the Super Bowl.
The truth is, unless I'm
getting paid a lot of money,
I don't really care to share
my thoughts with you people.
Here is how Belichick's Patriots
will be remembered:
the tuck rule, spygate,
and deflategate.
Forgive me if I don't put stock
in what all these
concussed Neanderthals
say about their legacy.
If football is a game of inches,
then anyone in your organization
cheating, even a single time,
taints everything
from that point on.
Of course it helps
that there are no repercussions
because your
cradle-robbing owner
has a weekly slumber party
with the commissioner.
And if you believe Tom Brady
is the greatest quarterback
of all time,
you deserve to get butt-[bleep]
by Aaron Hernandez in prison.
Brady had one good year
of lobbing it up to Randy Moss,
and every other season he's been
a game manager.
He's Trent Dilfer
with hair plugs.
He's a Men's Warehouse model
who's married
to a talking horse model.
"Oh yeah, well, that horse model
is worth a billion dollars."
Yeah, that's because she's
a horse that can talk.
And how did that "class"
organization
celebrate their big win?
By all banging the same chick
on Tinder.
You're the Super Bowl champs,
swipe left once in a while.
I know,
I'm a bitter Dolphins fan.
You owe the Dolphins.
If the Patriots weren't in such
a [bleep] division,
you wouldn't have
such a cakewalk
to get into the playoffs
every year.
You need us.
Not as much as you need the Jets
and Bills.
But you need us.
And if you're a Pats fan
thinking,
"He doesn't have
the balls to say that
to my blotchy, alcoholic,
racist face,"
you are wrong.
I will be touring exclusively
in the New England area
this summer.
The Great Nor'easter Tour
of 2015 goes on sale tomorrow.
From Halifax to Hershey.
Why don't you go to Miami?
[bleep] those losers.